Film Courage: Ken of the many books that you’ve
written (and you have one you co-wrote entitled
Writing Treatments That Sell and maybe you
can hold it up so people can see it’s cool
cover there and first off can we define what
is a treatment?
Dr. Ken Atchity, author/producer: Well, it’s
one of the things that Chi-Li Wong and I looked
into when we wrote this book because we kept
getting asked that question by clients “What
is a treatment?”
We had to explain it over and over again and
then suddenly it occurred to us “What is
a treatment?”
ourselves?
What is their definition?
So we did a survey of about 30 execs in television
and film and asked them that question “How
would you define a treatment?”
And we asked them about 10 other questions
and we really based the book on their answers.
And so basically the answer is that a treatment
is a relatively brief written pitch written
story intended to be intended to be dramatized
for motion picture for film or television.
And it’s written in user-friendly, grammar-free,
quick language that is easy to follow and
it contains highlights the most important
characters events and the obligatory scenes
in the story.
So how long is the treatment?
Relatively brief, three pages to let’s say
15 pages.
Once it’s passed 15, 20 it’s getting no
longer relatively brief.
There was no industry agreement on it.
And basically treatments range from 5 to 10
pages (good treatments) and we recommend that
because of the attention span of who you are
dealing with (the audience), your reader (the
buyer).
His attention span is limited and you do not
want to extend it because he wont be there
or she wont be there at the end of the story
if you make it too long.
So that’s basically what a treatment is
and it’s used for two purposes.
It diagnoses the faults in the story.
So you write a treatment of the story to see
your faults in it, so it’s a diagnostic
tool and then you fix them and then it becomes
a sales tool because people are willing to
read a treatment when they wont read a script
because a script is a serious engagement whereas
a treatment can be read relatively quickly.
And it’s used in every part of the industry
and it’s different from a synopsis because
a synopsis is a dry fully detailed summary
of a story.
You’d find a synopsis in a coverage for
example but the treatment is a pitch.
It’s the substitute for a live pitch.
I’m doing a webinar called Pitch Perfect
which is about pitching and when you get the
rare occasion to do that.
But now with the Internet, we are going to
do it virtual pitching so that people can
actually pitch to a producer and get an answer.
And a pitch is an extremely fortunate chance
to sell your story.
And again you do not want to be prefacing
it with anything.
You don’t want to reveal your personality,
that’s not what it’s about.
You want to just tell how strong your story
is by showing the story and a treatment is
the best you can do if you don’t have the
opportunity to pitch live.
So the treatment replaces the pitch and is
what most people use and use it through email
and any other method they have to hand a piece
of paper to someone else.